we are back now at 7 30 with a
spectacular failure to launch a setback
for jeff bezos's blue origin space
program the new shepard rocket the very
same type that has carried celebrities
to the edge of space and back crashed to
earth after its launch yesterday in west
texas that's the
capsule on top no one was on board and
the capsule did parachute down safely
however the faa has grounded blue
origins rockets until an investigation
is completed the company says that the
safety system worked as designed focus
on the positive they are not at this
time saying what went wrong mark
straussman has more now on the failed
launch
one
it was the ninth flight of this new
shepard rocket carrying three dozen
science experiments to the edge of space
but about a minute into its climb a
malfunction the on-board computer
sensing trouble jettisoned the capsule
up and away from the failing booster it
appears we've experienced an anomaly
with today's flight it's not yet clear
why the booster failed and fell back to
earth crashing out of camera view no
people were inside the capsule it
descended under parachutes and appeared
to land normally call it a successful
failure made possible by a key safety
feature installed in the center of the
capsule the escape system
come on into the capsule blue origins
ariane cornell showed us last year
there's any issue detected with the
rocket we've got the rocket the capsule
on board on top we will fire
this escape mower to get the capsule far
and fast away from the booster
new shepard is the workhorse rocket of
blue origin space tourism business since
last summer it has successfully flown 31
people on six flights
those human flights use a different new
shepard booster and capsule than the
ones involved in monday's mishap
but for now all flights are on hold
while the faa investigates
for cbs morning's mark strassman los
angeles